ils sont six de la brigade orange à
circuler à vélo leur public les lycéens
de la cité scolaire de fort de france
entre le lycée schoelcher et celui de
bellevue le rôle de ces médiateurs
apaiser les conflits éviter les
raquettes et les vols à l'arraché par
exemple ce travail pour si justement au
bon fonctionnement de la cité scolaire
parce qu'à un moment il y avait une
reconnaissance d'une violence quand même
assez forte au niveau du lycée pour
intervenir
les médiateurs n'ont qu'une seule arme
que le verbe cela veut dire que
lorsqu'il y à un conflit au niveau de la
cité scolaire et ben nous sommes une
équipe de trois nous allons voir les
protagonistes de l'histoire et à ce
moment là on essaie de calmer la tension
on essaie de calmer les conflits c'est
pas tout le temps évident à proximité
des établissements scolaires
ils sont vus comme des grands frères
c'est utile pas pour les profitation
pour tout ce qui est bague autour des
lycées autres
même en ville light ont arrêté c'est
pourquoi faire attention
ce sont des petits conseils qui pourtant
sont importants où ils sont très
importants oui ça montre qu'ils veulent
ma sécurité
voilà en plus des polo orange il y a
aussi les polo gris ces médiateurs
circule en voiture ou à moto dans toute
la ville de fort de france
ce matin avant de rejoindre leurs
collègues à vélo ils ont été dépêchés
sur un fait divers
quand vous arrivez sur place ici quel
est votre rôle sécuriser les lieux pour
pape aux badauds pour que puisse pas
filmer tout et tout et puis voilà
les médiateurs travaillent étroitement
avec la police nationale et municipale
mais aussi avec les associations
ces collaborations ne pallie pas le
manque de moyens humains et matériels
que dénonce ces hommes de terrain